[Musique]
oui bonjour oui bonjour je m'appelle
Valérie j'ai 22 ans
alors voilà j'ai un petit souci c'est
que bon j'ai eu plusieurs plusieurs
petits amis mais je n'ai jamais voulu
avoir des relations sexuelles avec eux
et je suis avec quelqu'un depuis
quelques semaines et bon j'ai envie là
cette fois-ci de franchir le pas donc
j'appréhende un petit peu le premier
rapport et j'ai surtout je sais pas trop
si je dois lui dire ou pas parce que
c'est la première fois
si je crois que à tout point de vue
c'est bon c'est nécessaire d'abord parce
que je crois que le fait que tu lui
dises j'ai 22 ans j'ai jamais eu de
rapport et c'était avec toi que j'ai
choisi de d'avoir le premier c'est quand
même c'est c'est un cadeau c'est un don
qui mérite que tu le que tu le soulignes
et puis il faut aussi réaliser que
puisque c'est la première fois que tu
appréhenses un petit peu malgré tout
même si même si maintenant ça y est tu
es prête psychologiquement et
physiquement comme tu as une certaine
appréhension le fait de lui dire bon
écoute c'est la première fois je pense
que lui automatiquement va être
peut-être plus attentif plus que les
plus patients sûrement plus doux et puis
que ça se passera beaucoup mieux pour
tous les deux donc je crois que c'est
très important que tu le lui dises
[Musique]
ne se transmet pas par la sueur qu'on
fasse du sport qu'on fasse n'importe
quoi donc pas de problème tu peux
continuer à faire du sport sans crainte
[Musique]
oui bonjour tu t'appelles comment tu as
quel âge
je m'appelle
Arnauds sexuels avec une copine et je
considère pendant les rapports et avec
avec ma copine ça gêne et moi aussi
alors comment je pourrais se passe
vraiment beaucoup
bon et tu restes pas trop habillé il
fait pas trop chaud
ça t'est arrivé très souvent
bah écoute je crois quand même qu'il
faut admettre que dans les rapports
sexuels il y a une activité physique qui
est parfois assez intense que donc c'est
comme un sport et je crois qu'il faut
accepter le fait que lorsqu'on fait un
sport on transpire lorsqu'on a des
rapports sexuels c'est c'est normal de
transpirer aussi donc je vois pas
tellement de solutions à ton problème
je suis désolé c'est mais en plus bon
beaucoup ta copine
c'est pour ça
écoute je sais pas je crois que
on va on va réfléchir à ton problème
éventuellement
tu laisses ton numéro autre appellera et
puis on essaiera de revoir ça un peu en
antenne mais là j'ai pas de solution à
te miracle à proposer pour l'instant
alors on t'appelle un peu plus tard
d'accord tu laisses son numéro oui vas-y
Olivier
Stéphane et alors et à la classe de 5e 7
du mois d'août allô oui bonjour tu
t'appelles comment Véronique Véronique
tu as quel âge 19 ans
on pose ta question
j'aurais voulu savoir si quand on arrête
la pilule on tombe en fait immédiatement
et si oui est-ce que faut se protéger
avant parce que il paraît d'après ce que
j'ai entendu dire qui risque d'y avoir
des anomalies pour l'enfant
de poser la question parce que lorsqu'on
décide de faire un bébé après avoir pris
la pilule effectivement il faut
s'arrêter quelques mois et pendant cette
période là il est souhaitable d'avoir
des rapports protégés pour éviter toute
grossesse précoce on se donne au minimum
trois mois idéalement six mois
il peut y avoir des troubles de
l'ovulation qui ont été déclenchés par
la prise prolongée de la pilule mais
c'est pas obligatoire donc il peut y
avoir quelques fois fécondation dès le
premier cycle qui suit l'arrêt de la
pilule et puis quelquefois c'est
plusieurs cycles plus tard ça c'est ça
dépend de chaque personne mais de toute
façon il est quand même préférable c'est
une précaution qui n'est pas forcément
indispensable mais il est préférable
d'avoir des rapports protégés pendant au
moins les trois mois qui suivent l'arrêt
je vous remercie
Fernando très bien tu veux poser ta
question
[Musique]
en classe
ça me gêne
tu as quel âge Fernando
13 ans bon alors écoute c'est normal tu
es en pleine puberté c'est normal
pendant la puberté d'avoir comme ça de
pas pouvoir contrôler complètement son
corps c'est comme s'il y avait un
véritable orage en ce moment d'hormones
dans ton corps tu peux pas maîtriser
tout ça alors notamment les érections
incontrôlables bon rassure-toi tous les
garçons de ton âge ça leur arrive
effectivement s'il y a des moments où
c'est pas la commode parce qu'on peut
pas prévoir et puis en classe il faut un
peu gênant on a l'impression que tout le
monde s'en aperçoit tout le monde vous
regarde bon rassure-toi c'est pas le cas
et tous tes copains sont en tout cas
voilà donc c'est pas c'est pas grave
c'est normal
d'accord Fernando à très bientôt bon on
va attaquer tout de suite si vous voulez
bien docteur avec la première question
allô
[Rires]
voilà être avec
excusez-moi j'étais tendance
sensationnelle c'est à dire que à chaque
fois qu'il arrive un problème dans ma
famille j'ai tendance à être encore un
peu plus volumique
oui
tu as quel âge 13 ans excuse-moi j'ai
pas entendu ton prénom
et tu dis que tu es boulimique mais
c'est toi qui dit que tu es boulimique
ou bien c'est ta famille qui le dit ou
c'est ton médecin
c'est mon médecin ma famille et moi et
toi aussi d'accord tu passes combien
Vincent
combien
en trop mais à quel moment tu manges
trop
[Rires]
donc quand tu as des problèmes quand tu
as des angoisses
écoute c'est difficile de parler de la
boulimie comme ça en une minute parce
que c'est quelque chose de d'important
il y a des tas de façon pour t'aider
mais c'est une histoire qui met
longtemps avant d'être réglé ça je pense
que tu as déjà expliqué
tu es suivi par un psychologue ou pas
Avignon
écoute moi je vois parfois les problèmes
de cet ordre chez certains enfants
j'ai remarqué qu'il y a une chose qui
permet de d'améliorer quand même quand
on a de grosses angoisses comme ça qui
ont très à la mort qui ont très à la
maladie qui entraîne l'hospitalisation
de gens qui sont chers c'est sur les
traitements homéopathiques qui peuvent
être remarquablement efficace donc je ne
te dis pas que ça suffira à régler tous
les problèmes mais ça pourrait
éventuellement t'aider je crois qu'il
serait bon que tu demandes à tes parents
de voir un homéopathe
et puis à côté de ça pas trop manger et
puis faire un peu de sport
ok Vincent à très bientôt allô allô
bonjour je m'appelle Laetitia j'ai 14
ans ça humanise à l'aide docteur giga
alors je voudrais savoir
est-ce que le coca peut avoir des effets
néfastes sur le corps ou sur la peau
parce que j'ai une peau assez acnéique
et j'ai une amie qui m'a dit que ça
pouvait venir de ça du coca alors déjà
l'acné n'est jamais d'origine
alimentaire on peut reprocher les tas de
choses au coca on peut reprocher les tas
de choses à juste titre aux boissons
sucrées ou aux autres ou aux autres
formes de sucreries mais ce ne sont pas
les responsables de l'acné ça c'est déjà
une première chose bon l'autre point
est-ce que le coca est mauvais bon je
crois que le principal problème du coca
c'est que c'est un excitant et donc si
on en consomme trop forte quantité et
surtout le soir on va voir les problèmes
d'insomnie par ailleurs c'est un produit
qui peut être intéressant ce plan
digestif ça peut être un excellent
médicament aussi dans les
gastro-entérites mais je crois qu'ils
font on a dit beaucoup de beaucoup de
mal on a des alors entre la pub et tous
les tous les mots dont on l'a accablé
bon le coca c'est pas si mal finalement
de toute manière maintenant
du collège Bernard Palissy en
particulier à Émile Louis à sa soeur
Claire à Elodie gérer ainsi qu'un index
gourdine je vous fais un gros bisou à
tous les deux salut salut au revoir
[Musique]